so but so let's move on next i want to
ask you
uh
considering everything you've been
through do you want to give us a run
through of where you've been like what's
been happening since january 6 uh to
start from the beginning sure absolutely
um
just starting with january 6 forward
well yeah like how did you come to how
did you tell us what happened you know
yeah yeah
so um after the election in 2020 um i'd
say somewhere around november
5th or 6th or 7th in those early days
afterwards
um
i was one of the people who decided to
lend my voice there were a number of
conservative
influencers who kind of decided to go to
swing states around the country and
basically throw
rallies and you know first amendment
protected events to kee to encourage
people to basically like keep the energy
up and say hey we want an audit we feel
like something's wrong everybody i mean
millions of people thought something was
wrong
and uh so i went to the state of
michigan
and i lin i lended my voice to three
rallies when i was there and then i went
to dc for a couple and so i was very
much involved in this what ended up
being called the stop the steel movement
and
uh
on january 6 i got invited to speak in
dc at the capitol um it was i
there were graphics that were made for
the speakers i was one of probably a
hundred people or more who had a graphic
that there was supposed to be an event
at the capitol so it was always my
understanding that president trump was
going to speak at the ellipse that there
would be a march from the ellipse to the
capitol and that there was going to be a
second event at the capitol uh i was
told it was a permitted event which i
believe it was there was a stage etc
and uh so on that day everything sort of
unfolded for me exactly as i was i was
told that it would president trump said
now we're all going to march peacefully
and patriotically to the capitol and i'm
going to join you there
so i started heading to the capitol on
the dc metro
for my speaking engagement
and um as i was arriving at my stop i
started getting some text messages on my
phone from people who i i'm friends with
or work colleagues of mine who were at
home throughout the country watching on
television saying you know we're hearing
on the news that people are going inside
the building
and
i didn't know what that meant because i
have attended dozens and dozens of right
wing rallies over the years and
that type of thing never happens with
conservative people i mean conservative
people are very very calm peaceful so to
hear that just it sounded strange to me
and honestly the first image that it
brought up in my mind
was i thought to myself when left-wing
protesters like alyssa milano even and
amy schumer for a number of different
causes have gone inside of government
buildings have gone inside the capitol
and you know pounded on
congress people's doors or made noise
gotten dragged out you know usually it
lasts like six seconds and they get
pulled out and the other thing that i
thought was that i was envisioning in my
mind like maybe a dozen people you know
when they're saying people are going
inside i thought like oh you know a few
people went inside to be like we want an
audit and they're going to get pulled
out and whatever
so as i
get to the stop i get off and i'm
heading toward the capitol and i just
decided to start shooting a video and
again i've done enough events to know
that if you're in a large crowd of
people live streaming is just not even a
possibility so i was like you know i'm
just going to record this into my camera
roll on my phone and then if i capture
anything interesting i'll cut it down
and put it out on social media later so
i'm approaching the capitol from the
east side this is the east side of the
capital this is the west side of the
capitol
this is a very important point to me
that i make every time i do an interview
because the conservative media has done
a terrible job of covering this story so
most people even people who are
supportive of people who got arrested
don't understand this
when you've seen the footage on the news
of um
windows being smashed and struggles with
police officers and flashbangs and
things like that as far as i know that
happened exclusively in the crowd on the
west side of the building people were
breaking windows and going inside so i
didn't witness any of that none none of
that and in my video which everything
i'm about to say
you can watch with your own eye you
don't have to take my word for it just
my video tells the same story i started
shooting my video about three blocks
away from the capitol
and just took one long continuous video
as i'm entering the east side capitol
grounds what you'll see in my video is
that there are zero police officers not
a couple not a zero zero police officers
people are standing all over the grounds
calmly people are walking their dogs
people are
carrying their babies people are
everyone's calm everyone's just
chit-chatting and as i wa there's there
are no barricades
there's a very very large sidewalk on
the east side i mean large enough that
you could drive cars on it and it's
completely open there's bike rack over
on the left in the lawn and bike rack
over on the right on the lawn but the
sidewalk is open this is all in my video
i followed the sidewalk up to the
capitol where there were
several thousand people standing around
the steps
in my video you see at the top of the
steps a man motioning down to people
below and he's calling out they've
opened the doors they're letting us in
we're going inside we're going inside
i repeated what he said as i'm filming
and then i went to the top of the stairs
and when i got to the top of the stairs
sure enough both doors were wide open
double doors large metal double doors of
the capital wide open and there's a
crowd of several hundred people at the
top of the stairs uh nobody's being
violent nobody's hurting any each other
anybody
um
it was loud it was a little bit loud but
um
and there were people standing in front
of me you know i was about 35 feet away
from the open doors and a lot of people
taller than me in front of me and people
a lot of people were carrying flags on
poles that were hanging down
so what i did was while my camera was
filming this video i hold my extended my
arms fully above my head and pointed
them down toward the door so that my
camera could capture things that my eyes
could not see
and i stood there for about eight
minutes on the east side steps filming
as some people were making their way
into the east side doors open doors and
some people most people were just
standing there either filming or just
kind of watching
and
after about eight minutes a man came
outside of the capitol he got on a bull
horn he shouted into the bullhorn
they've cleared congress everyone's left
the building
clear out clear out
and at that moment i immediately turned
around i told the people behind me
they're saying to clear out go this way
go this way you were you in the building
i never went inside the building i
didn't get within 35 feet of going
inside of the building and there were
literally hundreds of people between me
and the doors and the crowd wasn't
really moving it wasn't a quickly it
wasn't a stampede i mean it was
literally just like people kind of
shoulder to shoulder like like going
like this
and um so i left the capitol grounds and
i went back to my hotel room in dc and i
took the video that i just shot and i
uploaded it to twitter
it was um i think about eight and a half
minutes long
and i i don't remember what i said but i
think i said something along the lines
of this is what i witnessed today at the
capitol
now at the same time that that was
happening
i started to see this energy changing on
twitter where i was starting to see all
these conservative talking heads
expressing like oh my god we're so
ashamed of what happened at the capitol
today we're so embarrassed oh this is
just the worst thing that's ever
happened and i thought that what i had
witnessed with my own eyes and what i
experienced i thought that was it i
thought that was the capital breach and
i'm thinking to myself you know it might
not have been like our finest moment but
i was like you know the doors were open
and people were walking in and you know
i don't know maybe they shouldn't have
gone inside but i'm thinking this is the
most embarrassing thing that people have
ever seen
and so i made a few comments uh you know
saying things like that i was not going
to um uh you know to speak against the
people at the capitol like all the other
conservative talking heads were i said
these are people that are desperate to
be heard nobody's listening to them you
know and
basically the comments that are making
that i was making made it sound like i
was in agreement with whatever had
happened at the capitol
about an hour after i uploaded that
video and had made a couple of comments
i turned on my tv and when i turned on
my tv from my hotel room that's when i
started to see images of people smashing
windows and struggling with police
officers and stuff and i i was really
shocked really really shocked and i was
just like what is this i couldn't even
understand what i was watching footage
of and when they were saying this was
what happened at the capitol i was
thinking
wow okay something went down today that
was very different than what i
experienced
and i instantly knew that people were
going to associate me with that if they
saw my video or they saw my comments and
that no one would be able to distinguish
and understandably no one would be able
to distinguish i wasn't there i was here
that was going on here i was you know so
i took the video down i took all my
tweets down for the entire day even the
ones i put on before i went to the
capitol i was just like i don't know
what happened i have no clue what
happened at the capitol and how bad it
was so even the comments that i made you
know at eight in the morning i i just
don't want and to be associated with
whatever this is in any way shape or
form so i deleted the video took the
tweets down and honest to god believe
that that was the end of it and flew
home the next day
um
and people started asking me right away
was i worried was i concerned because
even though my video had only lived on
twitter for like an hour or two it had
already been copied by numerous twitter
trolls so they were mass
reposting my video and tagging the fbi
and telling the fbi to come and get me
and it was just getting worse and worse
and worse day after day so
uh it wasn't you know going away it was
intensifying and that was making me a
little uncomfortable and at that point i
thought well i'm i'm probably going to
get visited i i wouldn't be surprised if
uh if they ask me some questions because
this is just getting so and at this
point they were starting to arrest
people and the story was really picking
up and it was picking up but still
people were asking me on a daily basis
are you worried and i was like no i was
like well i didn't do anything i have
nothing to be worried about
and then
uh two and a half weeks later on monday
january 25th
um i woke up to a team of fbi agents and
tactical gear uh raiding my home at dawn
uh they got me out of bed put me in
handcuffs and presented me with a search
warrant
to take this a team of agents began
taking my computers my ipad my phones
hard drives thumb drives camera
equipment electronics while
two or three other agents put me in
handcuffs and told me that i was facing
multiple felony charges for what i had
done at the capitol on january 6th and i
remember i said felonies i said i didn't
even commit any crimes
and the guy said oh i saw your video i
saw what you did
and i started going what the hell did i
do like i mean i literally like i just
for a moment i was just like did i like
black out like did i do something like
egregiously violent and i don't remember
it or like what's going on
so they took me to jail
they put me in a cell where i sat for
two and a half days
uh before uh in 23-hour day lockdown
before i finally had the opportunity to
see a judge and the judge ordered my
release
when the judge ordered my release the
next morning i was able to speak with an
attorney
and
that's when my attorney who became my
attorney
informed me that i was being charged
with two felonies and a misdemeanor
so the first felony was
knowingly
occupying restricted grounds and this
word is very important to them in all of
these j6 cases knowingly everyone
knowingly was somewhere where they
weren't supposed to be and we chose to
do it anyway
and so i guess by standing on the
capitol steps during a protest i was in
a restricted area and i knowingly was in
this restricted area and they were
charging me with a felony for that and
for the record as far as i know
as far as i know i am the only person
who got charged with a felony for being
in the restricted area even people went
inside the capital were getting
misdemeanors for parading in a
restricted area or occupying a
restricted area but i got a felony for
being on the steps
then they charged me with a misdemeanor
of disorderly conduct with an intent to
to disrupt a hearing before congress
and the other charge was a felony
of impeding an officer in the line of
duty and i said what is this
and my it was explained to me in your
video that i'm shooting like this of
doors that are 35 feet away from me with
hundreds of people between me and my
camera
there's a moment where one capital
police officer comes to the open doors
the door frame
and when he gets there
the per somebody near him grabs his
plastic shield out of his hand
and when he when that happens a number
of voices it hundreds of people all
around me
a couple of voices in the crowd you hear
one shouting take the shield take the
shield and someone's is shouting take it
take it
well the fbi says you're the person
shouting take the shield take the shield
and you know you're this this influencer
with a lot of uh with a big following
and people listen to you and you have
this influence so by you shouting take
the shield take the shield
this is a you know an egregious act of
encouraging a crowd to impede an officer
and so they charged me with a felony
and um
so that began the process of what was a
year-long nightmare of
trying to find some sort of resolution
in this case what ends up happening with
the charges
long story short after a year uh i took
a plea deal
in the plea deal now you have to
understand too that in addition to what
i was already facing
they the doj
repeatedly uh messaged to my attorneys
and to me
that they had not yet charged me with
felony obstruction of congress and that
this was a charge that carried 20 years
they said we could
uh but we haven't we've chosen at this
point not to do that yet
so to me it felt very clear
that
uh if i chose not to take the plea deal
that they were offering that i would be
facing the two felonies that they were
already charging me with and that they
were going to add a third felony of
obstruction of congress which carries 20
years
and um
when we see the way that these dc the
people who are going to trial when we
see the way that they're going uh you
know people ask me all the time do you
feel like you made the right choice
taking a plea deal and i say well you
have to understand
the the question was never how do i win
and how do i lose it was how do i lose
the least this was an unwinnable
situation so how do i get out of this
and lose the least you know there was
one guy who got acquitted on trespassing
charges that's true he did he took a
bench trial
um the judge himself said that nobody
was trespassing case dismissed right
well i i think
and believe me that sent me into a
depression for a while and questioning
again if i had made the right decision
but the different the key differences in
his case and mine is that if i if if i'm
correct i don't think he was facing any
felonies i think he was facing three or
four misdemeanors and it was a pretty
clear-cut case that he had not committed
any violence vandalism theft or
destruction same with me
but that he was accused of
going inside parading
parading in a restricted area all of
these different things and that he had a
video that showed that there was a
police officer who motioned him in and
at that point the judge was like well
this is you can't charge him but
thinking he's in a restricted area when
he has this police officer motioned him
in i'm being accused of shouting
take the shield take the shield right
which i can't disprove that i don't
simply put the violence in all of the
chaos from that day you condemn oh
absolutely i always have yeah from the
very beginning so how did it work out
then with the with the plea deal you
took what happened so in the plea deal
they dropped the felony charges against
me they continued forward with the
misdemeanor charge of disorderly conduct
with an intent to disrupt congress
however
as
a piece of my plea deal it included a
document that they call the statement of
offense and in the statement of offense
um i
i it was a condition that i basically
confess to all of the things that they
had originally accused me of so the
statement of offense says
uh i went onto the grounds knowing that
the grounds were restricted
when i went onto the grounds i saw the
crowd struggling with police officers
and i encouraged the crowd
to struggle with police officers i saw
an officer having a shield ripped away
and i shouted
take it take it they changed it from
take the shield to take it take it
to encourage the crowd to take the
shield and i told my attorney i was like
i cannot sign this i abs i will not sign
this and so my attorney went back to
them and said he
he opposes this
and they said well then he can go to
trial if he has a problem with this this
document so my option was
take the deal as written or go to trial
and i took the deal so so either either
lie or face a very serious i'm not
saying that oh okay so uh what how did
the sentencing go what happens next do
you go to the judge so i pled guilty to
the misdemeanor um my sentence so they
continued my case five times over the
course of a year which was devastating
and excruciating um by the time we
finally got to sentencing which was in
almost an entire year i was arrested on
january 25th and i was sentenced on
january 24th of the following year
and um now you have to understand i have
no criminal record
this is uh a class b misdemeanor charge
which my lawyer said you know this is
akin to playing your music too loud a
class b misdemeanor yeah and um and the
judge real quick driving on a suspended
license is a class a okay it's like a
it's a harsher offense you get to a year
in jail for that right okay so class b
misdemeanor which the judge herself
referred to as a petty offense i mean
it's classified as a petty offense and i
got sentenced to
three months of house arrest
three years of probation
60 hours of community service the
maximum fine of five thousand dollars i
was ordered to pay five hundred dollars
restitution to the capital although it
was acknowledged that i didn't engage in
any violence or vandalism or destruction
to the capital in any way shape or form
and uh ordered to
to engage in court-ordered mental health
services so i had to go to a therapist
court-ordered therapist
and um
and
the government the prosecution actually
asked for during my sentencing the right
to
so i'm not so i've already been
sentenced to three years of probation
and the and the prosecution asked for
the right to as a condition of my three
years of probation that they have the
right to surveil my phone my computer my
email account my bank accounts and my
social media accounts for the three
years that i was on probation but the
judge did not grant them that but they
wanted it they wanted it
already doing that what right right
right just like you don't need it uh
what is probation what does that look
like what does it mean well you know at
this point i'll say that i'm fortunate
because i have a
a good probation officer and i think i i
don't want she's never said anything to
me to indicate how she feels about my
case but based off of the way she
interacts with me
um i get the indication that she sees
the case for what it is
and feels like she has better things to
do with her time than be managing me on
a constant basis but what does that what
does it mean for you like when you wake
up you got to call them or
how strict is it you want to go buy
groceries they're like you can't have
milk you're gaining weight or something
like that
no i mean by the way
thank you thank you house arrest was
like that um i was quite literally not
allowed to leave my house for three
months unless i was doing community
service which was restricted i mean it's
60 hours so i i'd
uh the option to leave my house for 60
hours to do community service they gave
you an ankle monitor i was i had an
ankle monitor um during that three
months and um she would make routine
visits to my house and i did
occasionally have to leave and do a
urinalysis and things like that
um
uh probation now that i'm off house
arrest probation is has not so far been
particularly strict uh she's gone above
and beyond to make sure that i have the
right and ability to travel as needed
she's not trying to restrict restrict me
from being able to move around and do
the work that i need to do
uh in fact the only real inhibitions
that i might ever face is so uh coming
here to do this show or anywhere else i
might need to go
uh let's just use as an example the
state of california if i need to travel
to the state of california for any
business or
okay uh
how about texas
all right if i need to travel to the
state of texas for any reason
she has to um contact the district in
texas that i'm traveling to their
probation office
and then they have to what's the purpose
of his travel what's he doing where is
he staying what's his flight number is
he renting a car what's the rental car
information so they have to gather all
this information and then they make a
determination about if they have any
issue with me traveling there or not so
it could technically happen but so far
has not happened yet and i've traveled
to
a number of blue districts where so far
no one has caused an issue and in fact
i'll be going to washington dc how do
you feel about the uh the response from
independent conservative media
starting with everything happened do you
feel that your story was accurately
represented that would imply that there
was any so
um no it's been terrible i mean it's
been terrible i've pushed really really
really hard to get my story out and i've
gotten to the point where
i've been successful and you know i was
interviewed by mark levin on levin tv
i just sat down with tucker carlson two
weeks ago on fox nation so we sat down
for an hour uh and that's on fox nation
uh but these have all been the result of
me pushing really hard for them to tell
my story
very few people have come to me and been
like this story needs to get out the
people need to know what happened i
think it's more of like a snowball
rolling down a hill you know i i i
hadn't heard much about the story at all
yeah and then uh we're hearing it now
i'm sure a lot of people are going to
hear it a lot of people are going to
want to know more and there's probably a
bunch of questions we'll have i think i
think more conversations will happen
well i'm incredibly grateful to you and
thank you for having me on no because
honestly
as far as the internet goes this is
certainly the biggest exposure that i've
had
in terms of the podcast no i mean that
and and i i mean honestly if there are
people i mean look if you if you started
a podcast yesterday and you have 13
don't reach out to me
i don't but i mean for anybody out there
who is a podcaster with a significant
audience i'm happy to come on and talk
we we booked you the same as we would we
booked anybody else like normal you know
what i mean it wasn't there was no
politics no debate yeah i was just like
hey brandon oh cool what um what would
you do different if there was like
another or what advice would you give if
people wanted to protest legally at the
capitol and there was something akin to
what happened how would you have done it
how would you do it differently and how
would you advise people to go about that
situation and not get into trouble but
still get the point across such a great
question so
i i think probably the biggest lesson i
learned from this was two things number
one we do absolutely exist in a
two-tiered system of justice so if you
are a conservative you're under much
more scrutiny than perhaps if you
support the black lives matter movement
or if you're a member of antifa or a
number of left-wing protesters who do
this kind of thing all the time like
jane fonda who stood exactly where i
stood five fridays in a row uh
protesting climate change and was
arrested five fridays in a row and had
her charges dropped for all five times
that she was arrested so there is a
two-tiered system of justice so you need
to be aware that if trouble breaks out
get the hell out of there as fast as you
can because you can find yourself
ensnared in something unwittingly uh and
you they're not going to let you off
you're you're i mean their favorite
thing in the world is to put out a
headline that says you know trump rioter
dot dot dot and you could be a 67 year
old woman with no criminal record you
could be 73 years old they don't care
it's as long as they get the trump right
or headline that's all that's important
the second thing i would say is
be really really aware
that
there could be a lot more going on than
what you're witnessing with your own
eyes i mean that to me personally is
probably the biggest lesson i didn't
stop to consider that this is a
four-sided building with people on all
four sides and that there could be
something much larger going on on any of
these sides than what i was witnessing
with my own eyes it's almost like the
jurisdiction's so big it should be
quadranted off so that you would only
charge people in certain quadrants with
activity within that quad that would be
fair like that's like a city block you
don't arrest a guy on the left side of
this in the west side of city block is
what somebody on the east side did that
would be fair uh and and that's again to
me one of the biggest fail failures from
the conservative media of not even me
like i have made that point to people
like tucker cross i'm brilliant people
mark levin tucker carlson almost
everyone i talked to says wow i didn't
even think of that and i'm like yeah i
mean there were
any you could be arrested on january 6
for being on capitol grounds and
throwing a gum wrapper on the ground and
you know get a littering charge but
you're still going to be listed mega
rioter arrested on january 6th because
you happened to be anywhere in the
vicinity of that building and got
arrested i mean
i honestly do believe that what happened
to me is
absurd
but
if
you know if they had come to me and said
look you're a big influencer you've got
a large audience we're charging you with
a misdemeanor of disorderly conduct i
would have been like
okay i mean if you really feel like you
need to do this fine but the idea that i
was at one point possibly facing three
felony charges for eight minutes that i
stood outside of the capitol holding a
camera in my hands they acknowledged
there was never one moment where anyone
said we think you might have been
violent we think you might have been uh
then uh vandalizing we think you might
have been destroying property they said
from the beginning we know you didn't do
any of those things but we do think that
uh
they they said that they thought that
that was my voice i i don't believe that
they thought that but they said that
they thought that that was my voice
and um
that was the harshest thing i mean that
was the biggest thing that i was accused
of was saying the words take it take it
and um
i ended up at one point almost facing
three felony charges that because on the
other side of the building
crazy things were happening
they wanted to make an example i suppose
well they weren't even that wasn't even
a secret in the 30-page sentencing
recommendation that they wrote on my
misdemeanor charge wow they said
numerous times you should read it oh man
uh did i know something funny what i got
charged with the cla i brought the
suspended license thing because i've
been charged with a class a misdemeanor
once you know my penalty was what it was
i think 150 dollar fine
that's it well good for you and they
said and they said my mind's bigger than
your [ __ ]
well no no my point is the absurdity of
what you went through on a class b
disorderly conduct yeah so uh when i was
i think i told the story before i was uh
i think i was 19 or 20.
i didn't know that if you got two
speeding tickets they suspended your
license
and i didn't what i was going to fight
one of them because it was bunk it was a
bad ticket but i was like it's easier
just to pay it and i asked a family
member just to cover it for me instead
of having to deal with going to court i
didn't realize that was an admission of
guilt i was like 19. and so then i'm
driving back from colorado i get pulled
over the cop says you're under arrest
suspended license i was like what i was
like i was in colorado i just got back i
had no idea and they're like tell to a
judge so i got i bonded they even arrest
me they take me out of the car they say
you've been formally arrested here's
your ticket here's your court date
that's it i went to court
prosecutors had class a misdemeanor one
year in jail 2500 fined maximum penalty
if you plead guilty 150 bucks and i was
like okay
so that's it and it's a longer
the longer story is like i told the
judge i was being coerced because they
were threatening me with a year in jail
and he told me to get a lawyer talked to
a lawyer ultimately i said i guess i'll
plead guilty and they said 150 bucks you
can pay it right now and you're done and
this is off your record and i was like
wow for a class a misdemeanor tim's like
i could make way more than that in the
year that i would be in prison right but
the opportunity the reality was
a year in jail was never on the table no
judge or jury would sentence someone to
that right they always try to scare you
with the maximum but a 30-page
sentencing recommendation and a class b
misdemeanor oh yeah something doesn't
add up no no no and you know they went
through my social media
i was actually going to bring this up
earlier when you were talking about
people uh taking your your video clip
out of context where you were talking
about the the weapons and stuff nukes
i mean imagine if it wasn't left-wing
trolls but the department of justice
that's doing that to you because that's
literally in my 30-page sentencing
recommendation and again people can look
this up for themselves it's all over
online
they a number of times they went through
my tweets and things like that and they
would take words out of different tweets
and string a sentence together like i'm
not making this up it's in there like
one of the sentences in my sentencing
recommendation because they wanted me in
prison by the way they wanted prison
time for my eight minutes outside of the
capitol holding a camera
and
one of the things that they said was you
know if you look at mr strzok's twitter
he tells the patriots that we are in a
civil war and that we've got to fight
back if we don't want to but i mean
literally these are all from different
tweets and they strung together a
sentence the washington post look it up
the washington post did a story saying
mega influencer was calling for a civil
war about me it's a story about me
calling for a civil war i'm like i was
on the steps with my camera
you know but that's what that's what
this is trump these are press releases
you said they did with trump he re-truth
someone who said civil war and they were
like trump calls for a civil war yeah
that's right it was probably me
washington post it says january 6th in
florida oh they changed the sub the
title first originally said brandon
strzok stewart rhodes both call for
civil war quote and then they would go
to the website if they change it jan six
influencers call for civil well that's
better
yeah yeah okay realize there's no
defamation now here's the new story
donald trump re-truth someone who said
the word civil war that's the story
that's right if you didn't say so what
you can infer from that is if you didn't
call for civil war is this a defamation
case the washington post claims you did
the tweet that i put out that they got
that from was me saying
make your peace right now with the fact
that we're in a civil war i said we
didn't want it and we didn't call for it
but they've started it something now i
want to even clarify that statement
when we talk about a modern civil war
we're not talking about people grabbing
their muskets and going out and like you
know going to the battlefield or
something i'm talking about being uh
banned from like i have been banned from
using paypal venmo stripe i'm not
allowed to send funds back and forth
people are literally having their bank
accounts shut down that's what a modern
civil war looks like it looks like when
people have a political ideology and
they control all the technology and
they're preventing people from being
able to exist in the digital space that
to me is what a modern civil war looks
like thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you